hey Luke here's the outdoor boys YouTube
channel and we made sword and shield and
I kinda regret it
[Music]
well I'm really excited about this
project you know I use gonna be a really
fun thing for Nathan and Tommy in my
mind it's awesome so hopefully it'll
turn out that way
my biggest regret about this project is
that my dad isn't down here in Virginia
to do this with me he's into woodworking
and I think he would really he'd really
have a lot of fun with this project it'd
be a fun little thing to do for the
grandkids but we're gonna plow ahead and
we're gonna get started and see what we
can do well me and sir Nathan here we
need to pick up some supplies for this
project so we are here at Lowe's and
we're gonna see if we can't get some
tools and some wood and get started some
fun so here we go
which one do you like better buddy the
green one
all right you get the green one down fun
Nathan ready all right guys to get
started we're gonna do the swords first
and I've got this 8 foot long piece of
lumber here it's a 2 inch by 1/2 inch I
think it's made from birch or pine or
something just a couple bucks at the
hardware store and this is what we're
gonna make the swords out of all right
so I got a piece of wood in the bench
vise and I'm going to make this sword
about oh it's probably gonna be about
three feet long okay and this is just
eyeballing it it doesn't have to be
exact none of these dimensions have to
be exact so you can see I've got a chunk
for the cross guard the handle of the
sword and then the point of the sword
[Music]
[Applause]
well look at that I'm pretty pleased
with that that looks legit man I'm
already feeling like a swordfight night
so let's get the cross guard on this
thing and go from there
so this is the cross guard and I'm gonna
cut a square hole in this so I can slide
this up and it'll fit snugly right there
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to take the end piece from one of our
scraps I'm gonna lay it down and what I
believe to be the middle all right there
we go now one of the things we've got to
keep in mind is that we want the hole to
go up to the black line but not over the
black line
[Music]
[Applause]
all right there we go a somewhat square
hole let's see if it fits
oh there we go snug as a bug in a rug
let's pop that off and finish the
crossguard there we go got the cross
card done now we need to sand everything
now this is definitely a type of project
you could sand by hand but I get
extremely bored sanding I hate sanding
so I'm going to use my angle grinder
all right so I'm gonna start with some
80 grit I'm gonna start sanding it want
to sand pretty much everything but not
here where the cross guard is fitting
we've got that snug don't mess with it
[Music]
just broke a piece off this pummel maybe
I'll just glue it back on yeah that's my
best option but I need to keep working
on my project
all right this here is what I call poor
man's router table so I've got a hand
router I've put in the bench vise and
I've clamped a guide on to it and we're
gonna see if we can't make a straight
little groove in the middle of the blade
all right there we go I've got this
groove that I've beveled right down the
middle of the blade on both sides it's
not perfect you can kind of see where
there's some wiggle in it and some
changes in depth but it's it's
acceptable and I'll sand it down a
little bit and that'll take out some of
the imperfections make it a little less
obvious but it's looking pretty good
well man this looks pretty good I'm
pretty pleased with this feels nice
looks nice the kids are gonna love this
so while this is finishing drying I'm
gonna go put it inside start working on
the second sword
all right got that done really quick
that second one went fast one thing I
did different is I made the handle
skinnier first off I think this one's
gonna be for Nathan he's got smaller
hands second of all I'm gonna be
wrapping the handle in paracord which
will make it thicker so to compensate I
think I should have made the handles
thinner in the first one also I left
this flared at the bottom I'm gonna and
I'm gonna hit this with the angle
grinder rather than the jig saw which
caused it to break last time so learning
a little bit learning a little bit here
but this looks slick well hot darn folks
I'm moving a lot faster it took me about
an hour and a half to do the first one
and I think I did the second one in
about 15 minutes
so you know once you get all set up and
know what you're doing this moves a lot
faster another thing I'm doing
differently is that I'm going to put the
bevel in before I grind the edges the
edge is what I use to guide this to make
sure it's straight so I don't want to
mess up the edge before I'm beveling so
another lesson learned
[Music]
well this is going by so much quicker
and working out so well so if you've got
a bunch of kids or a bunch of grandkids
you're making this project for
definitely the second and third and
fourth one will go by much faster so
alright let's stand this thing down
alright I've got two swords and they're
pretty close to the same size looking
good so I'm gonna set these aside I
still want to give that that glue time
to dry and I want to paint everything at
the same time so I'm gonna move on to
the shields
alright here's a piece of that five
millimeter birch plywood and we're gonna
start cutting out patterns it's not
thinking about what I'm gonna make this
look like huh all right so I'm gonna
stencil of what I want to make I'm gonna
cut it out with my knife and we're gonna
go from there
alright so we got a little rough stencil
here I'm gonna trace it with the sharpie
and we're gonna start cutting he needed
you you want to see what I've been
working on okay check this out yeah it's
not finished yet I still need to work on
it well what do you think yeah you like
that yeah that's the right size it's a
proper like hand and a half for you
[Music]
all right there we go not too shabby
[Music]
alright I've got the two shields cut out
and I've sanded the edges so now I need
to curve them a shield should be curved
slightly so I'm trying to think about
how to do that or whether it's even
worth doing that and I could steam it
but I don't have a steam box so I'd have
to make a whole steam box thing I'm
gonna put some thought in how to do this
alright so I'm gonna try to boil try to
make a little trade okay so I'm just
barely covered the shield water put it
in there and we let it sit and I have no
idea how long we have to let it sit
alright so the shields are steaming in
the oven that's gonna take a little bit
of time and I'm still waiting on that
glue to dry so I'm gonna I want to build
a little something extra a little bonus
item
[Applause]
[Music]
well I didn't plan on making this but I
had the bits laying around and I was
killing some time so why not all right
little pull acts look well the shields
have been in the oven for about two
hours now and I have no idea how long
they need to be in there before I can
bend them I really have no clue never
done this before so I'm gonna pull one
of them out and just test and see what
happens oh that's actually bad it's not
evenly
well the steaming worked kind of it's
definitely bending but still laminating
as well look at that so we're gonna let
it dry get its shape and then maybe
throw some wood glue on it and see if we
can fix it okay let's see how this is
doing here all right that looks pretty
good
I'm not gonna monkey with it anymore
let's get it painted
[Music]
Oh Nathan you broke it you broke it off
didn't even get a chance to finish
painting it that was just an experiment
I guess that was kind of a weak spot oh
yeah look at that broke it off right
there
oh I didn't take long all right so I've
got the shields done and they're bent
all right but look at this they're
completely de laminated and they're kind
of just all weird and warp this one's
garbage too I mean they're just well
I've got two more shields cut out got
them sanded I'm just gonna go ahead and
paint them not gonna monkey around with
try to bend them or anything over the
last few days I keep spray-painting
layers of paint on to this stuff it
takes several layers to get the colors
right but I need to tape up the handles
now and spray the blades silver and I
need to keep hitting the shields with a
few more layers I can still see some of
the plywood riding through the red paint
so I keep going till that is gone
by the way I'm in a suit because I'm
doing this in between trials and I just
try to knock this out on my lunch break
about three or four layers of metallic
spray paint have done a good job of
making these cross guards look shiny and
gold you can see that the swords look
silver but not particularly shiny yet so
I think I'm gonna put a few more layers
of silver paint metallic paint on the
blades to make them really shiny then
what I'm gonna do is I am going to put
some black on here and I'm gonna work on
the design
yeah buddy
[Music]
oh yeah we did all right
[Laughter]
[Applause]
alright you gotta admit that looks
pretty cool pretty proud of that this is
gonna be awesome so I'm gonna set this
aside and we're gonna check out the
swords here let's get the tape off now
let's take see if we can get this on
yeah your dragon look at that all right
I need to measure your arms okay so
we're good put a hole there I'm gonna
put a hole there hole right there
[Music]
Oh freak yeah polyurethane is dissolving
the gold paint that really really sucks
it looks like it's doing something
similar to the silver paint this mini
wax fast-drying polyurethane is
completely destroyed the metallic paint
it's been okay on the polar bear shield
because there's no metallic paint on it
but it started to smear the dragging a
little bit and it ruined the blade on
the sword so no the other sword I'm not
going to seal with polyurethane it just
kind of is what it is and I'll let that
sword dry and we'll kind of go from
there we'll just kind of back off let
everything dry here and we'll
troubleshoot once it's dry
all right now I just gotta let the glue
dry on the paracord handle well guys I
woke up this morning worrying about how
the the sword would look after that
polyurethane melted the the paint on it
it actually looks really good
I mean it's messed up the paint a little
bit on the cross guard you can see where
some of the silver got on there but it's
kind of just made it look like old brass
kind of giving it a patina but it's not
bad I think I'm not gonna do anything to
it it looks good enough so I'm really
happy with how that turned out and check
out these shields boom those look
awesome
now if you want to do the same thing but
you don't really have a ton of artistic
talent where you can draw something like
this freehand or make your own stencils
don't worry there's a couple things we
can do first off you can order like
stickers online that you could put on
big decals that you could put on that
are really cool or you can just print
off an image or design on your printer
and then cut it out with the exacto
knife and make the stencil out of it or
a picture from a magazine at them and
don't overthink it I mean kids love this
stuff even if it doesn't look super
freakin amazing
okay yeah so you know just have fun with
it well there we go got the handle down
on the sword just gonna let that glue
dry
[Music]
all right there we go there's the
handles done nice now let's do the polar
bear shield but the armbands on nice
well there we go we've got two swords
and two shields for my little boys now
here comes the best part of the entire
project they're gonna give it to the
boys let's see how fast they turn on
each other and break stuff and we end up
taking him away you want to see the
shield
Sir Thomas that makes you a knight i wo
sir Nathan so you just hang tonight
they're hairy guys don't hurt each other
cuz you are Knights are you hiding from
a dragon now I have to run don't
[Music]
we can't tell mom I think I think your
shield put a big smark on the wall I
[Music]
love you well guys thanks for watching
the outdoor boys YouTube channel we hope
you enjoyed this video if you guys would
like to see more videos from the outdoor
boys YouTube channel don't forget to
[Music]